county commissioners have adjusted how
they're spending coronavirus relief
funds
the board is now focusing some of the
federal dollars to increase kova testing
and provide
aid 8 news now reporter kristen drummond
attended that meeting
and filed this report clark county
commissioners voted to essentially
move around the cares act money they're
transferring funds from certain
categories
to address the biggest needs in our
community that motion passes
the board approving the reallocation in
a 6-0 vote
a presentation at the meeting shows a
breakdown of the 295 million dollars in
coronavirus relief funds
commissioners budgeted for certain items
months ago but
recent trends highlight some areas now
need more money than others
that includes financial assistance for
mortgage rent
and bills the county originally
designated 30 million dollars to that
line item
now there's nearly 59 million dollars
reallocated to that category from other
services
the county also reassigned two million
dollars towards cobit testing
when we started this in march we had no
idea what our expenses would be
so we put together a fluid plan that we
could
reorganize as as we got closer to see
what the real need was
county staff tell me 46 million dollars
has been spent so far
on rental assistance commissioners
encourage anyone needing help
to apply online for the clark county
cares housing assistance program
also known as chap before december 30th
that is the cut-off date to submit an
application for eligibility
we want to try and work to stabilize
folks we have a link to the housing
assistance page on our website
8newsnow.com
reporting by the clark county government
center kristen drummond 8 news now
and the county's cares act money must be
spent on expenses from the pandemic
accumulated
between march and the end of december